hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Octodad they finally
released the short levels that I'm so
excited to be able to play them there's
only two available right now and I've
not played either of them and I haven't
played Octodad in a long time but I'm so
excited to be back if you guys don't
remember that I had the most incredible
emotional journey the last time that I
played Octodad it was triumph to his
tribulation it was highs and lows
valleys and under not valleys whatever
autumn mountains whatever either way I
am so sorry for the rude interruption my
recording crash and everything went
horrible so I had to start the game all
over again
hello baby how you doing it's good to
see you again
been a while you're looking good looking
fit plop ow okay let me go talk to the
waiter and slap his behind
I believe it's humbler fling him along
glee I don't see okay how dare you sir
let me just reach under oh yeah how's
that doing for you you like this bribe
wait no let me just caress your face
ever so gently however tells you how
handsome you okay you're obviously bored
at this okay honey excuse me do you have
any my okay I forgot how to play okay
this one hop nope not that one
yup okay not this either unless I'm
supposed to give him the coat Oh God
well that's a lot of dosh sorry ma'am
lady wife girlfriend of mine I don't
know what stage of the relationship
we're in yet hey hey if I could just
stop pole dancing for one second oh
sorry ma'am
wife girlfriend oh come on this is
Harvard ah God I forgot how hard this
was ah sir let me just slip this under
the table so delicately you drop this
buddy there you go so take me to my
table sir thank you excuse me I'll just
I'll lead the way okey-dokey then
I'm normal this is the seductive
pre-dinner dance
sit down with scarlet move nearly chair
and use your arms to sit ok don't mind
me I'm gonna oh ok that's what is my
legs supposed to go through huh ok
indeed it does my darling you look best
of all huh
right mutt right right in my face right
Jess and there we go I'm reading this
like a human would thing was just the
start you know I've got big plans ah
good to hear
babe oh sorry I'm going to win a
Pulitzer for my fearless devil-may-care
journalism okay what about your
questionable taste in men excuse me sir
what okay I'll be taking care of you
good night are you the man I bribed
order you look exactly like the man
arrived he'd like the halibut yeah wait
Jynx enjoys walked by you fish wait to
octopi eat fish was that good yeah good
not so mysterious after all we're
learning science and I have to try to
drink water
Hey huh Oh God I'm the best hat bath Oh
Rach okay well we should toast yeah Jos
you know up great glasses together a
wish something well toast to your health
to us all right okay to us
pink try drinking oh I'm gonna get it in
my mouth eventually baby don't you worry
a darn thing okay
Oh oh my goodness
sir hello don't love for me okay if I
could door I gotta get out of the chair
right my butt seems to be permanently
glued and we're off to the races here we
go
don't mind me everybody normal everyday
sorry scuse me
wait a minute that chef back there looks
from there all right familiar hey what's
in here yeah that sounds good your son
of a [ __ ] trying to make money here all
right so I need to go to the bathroom
but there's this door over here ah crap
Hey
you mind me being in here ah I pried on
one knee I want to disturb them hey
buddy how's it going friend man you look
good today you've been working out that
bollocks
BAM sorry I kind of went up your crotch
there a little bit
don't mind me okay bye hey come on can I
can I hear yogi
yeah all right then oh boy there we go
okay so I need to wash up so stick face
first okay
huh bring that up to face hot how am i
okay
come good goes there another secret
portal in the bathroom here if maybe
that I'll do okay well I wasn't able to
do this before anyway how would I be
able to do this now one foot in the
other foot okay yeah the foot kinda here
we go and Flusser rooney plus main
closed me I'm ready to be flushed
they're clogged hep head
oh yeah Greg uh this is not worth my
time
okay I'm out here sorry
I hope my date doesn't think I smell of
feces that would just be the worst hello
hello oh no the kitchen where we clean
up after you
what uh-huh okay then bye why am I doing
this
I know strange huh mix the sauce ho ho
Ha okay all right then well
uh is this pure blood this is the blood
of the Fallen this the blood of the
innocent okay
getting it get any good yeah
stomp the grapes stop the grapes who
does this and making juice huh yeah I
guess it wouldn't have time to ferment
on a bed book
okay then geez alright Han gotta put the
damn thing in the thing oh come on get
the jar there get the jar thank you hey
baby head
this can't be sanitary I'm just warning
everybody in here Phil scarlet sit your
chips class oh I'm gonna fill Scarlett's
glass with my juice huh alright then
okay alrighty then I forgot how
intuitive the controls of Octodad truly
was were I'm just gonna help out a
little more you're welcome
huh all righty then up no yeah there we
go and I got enough I guess there like
something in here that I need L whatever
I'm out here I got a date to be it's a
hot date well that's a problem someone
else is gonna deal with it okay hi hi hi
what are you looking at huh were you
looking at okay kid you want some chew
oh uh I tried baby trust me I tried yeah
I made it myself with Montana chol feet
yeah yeah lamb island oh boy not this
again okay oh it's so frustrating
okay ah foods almost here and we're good
yay oh wait this is just bread and
butter uh okay let's talk don't worry
I've got some icebreakers like what's
your favorite book No
salty hearts ill I didn't take no hey
hey lover boy take care of the other
customers before you get your flirt on
wait what do you mean I'm not gonna just
go with you and assume that I work in
this restaurant that's not okay why why
do you think that's okay why would I do
that I'm on a date I'm about to get some
sweet action from this lovely redhead
okay never mind I'm I'm failing to stay
strong huh bye I have to work okay take
the menus huh
okay guy you didn't need that oh boy was
I supposed to take that somewhere what
do you mean
this is not how a restaurant is run you
don't just pick up a customer who bribed
your frontman more uh-huh how much more
you need are you are you serious lady
okay whoa geez Wow all right and why
would you want to see that why would
anyone want to see that yeah frankly I
want to see that who wants it cake up
for grabs
oh you know yeah how about you up yep
oh you don't mind while i straddle your
dad here and sir you cake little lady
you're a lucky girl and I'm a lucky
octopus apparently um okay then oh come
on well they're gonna be so depressed
well I mean I am sitting in the dad's
lap right now very in twined with him so
I'm just gonna straddle his face go I'm
gonna go I'm gonna kid what go thank you
very much
okay this date is going wonderfully I'm
gonna score tonight
you like my stylist wine I drink the
juice
I should investigate that I know yeah go
for it
what is that what is that what is that
that's neither what's the most haunted
place you've ever been
oh my massive asylum
really yes
what the hell sure I'll go with that
I guess Hank herb Bernie that was good
I don't know what it was meatball on a
stick maybe why do I need to get back to
the kitchen why is it something that I
need to do I have enough trouble getting
out of this ding-dong-dang see people
stuff to learn everything there is to
know about them no okay bye
do you guys work at all even a little
bit what am I doing here why am I here
okay
no you know what forget it I'm not gonna
ask questions about this I tried to ask
questions what I prayed this the first
time okay thank you
okay what I'm gonna do this tenderize a
steak with a mallet saw mallet we're
gonna see him out oh it's over there
excuse me okay yeah okay
ah BOPE that's the sink whoa what's up
what the hell who is this
oh nothing this is what I'm supposed to
do give me that no that's a steak no God
biggest damn it no one cares
how's it still moving
all right hey I don't even know where
the stove is oh there it is
okay I'm gonna cook myself a little bit
here we go it's like the whoa did I do
that
all right toss the pizza dough okay
okay why is that ray that come from give
me the dough huh oh you didn't see
anything
Oh give it back what are you doing get
up
to freak around come on what is this
with the dough go with the dough go
where the dough go it was this over here
dude where the dough go no I'm I'm where
the where the oh it's back over there
what did it get back there
when was it gonna tell me that it went
back there yeah okay is that good enough
ha ha ha god damnit screw this oh oh
thank you
okay good enough oh god this is not okay
I'm burning okay let's calm down a
little bit
oh go the right way okay let's calm down
a little bit yep
give me you get that over there good
enough put the cheese on there cook the
pizza in the oven got to put this on the
bear would get out here get put this
there and then get off the table
okay grab this hop what to do piss hat
okay yeah we are
hmm good enough enough load the
dishwasher why am i doing that oh it's
already trying to do that before okay
well this is not normal but that's not
normal why is the mallet in there okay
so anyway neither this is okay yeah you
son of a [ __ ] I remember the mixed
emotions and I had last time I played
this alright okay we're fine bring the
pizza to the pizza couple how am I
supposed to know how am I supposed to
know get your foot in the right direct
okay there okay now we're back in normal
order and we don't need to hump why are
you going back in what are you doing
we're going is really going better
before okay alright then why is there
food literally every oh you okay you
wanted to share a pizza okay
Maina myself hand-tossed you're going
all of it have it yeah that's really
okay hey scarlet baby this place is
weird
we should blow this joint the only one
with secrets I've been doing some
digging Nevada
okay then aliens put human oh that's a
silly answer I can't grab okay I can't I
can't even it won't let me there we go
god okay there's no salad left in the
bowl Hey salad with your hands of course
I'll take yours apparently hello here
comes the airplane
any minute now there we go come on get
in the face get in my face get in my
face okay I'm assuming it wants me to
try one of these beets huh thank you
okay so kind of tip II got one here cuz
you want one lady Yu Tong griefer kale
it's nutritious and delicious yep Buki
yeah I don't know why an octopus
enjoying this so much
geez I'm not sure on a natural leader a
true artist
what what do you mean why do I have to
do everything there's a table that's
knocked over all right I'm out here the
professional is on his way don't you
mind I'll get this in one fell swoop
head in okay get scrape it all off let
gravity do most of the work that's the
trick
hey yep okay help help
they're good everybody's happy I guess I
did it Oh bleep and bring it around
bring this back
around okay still the wrong direction
any minute now we're gonna get back in
that chair
I don't overshot it and there we are
oh good our entrees are finally here I
love grilled halibut oh yes I will try
hit Oh saw my fish
oh okay whoops I need this yeah if I had
to choose I think I pick Venice
something about the water raised feel so
romantic
Oh Andy ADA yes I'm gonna show you a
union of land and sea later but that's
not for the kiddies what is going on in
the kitchen why is there bubbles hey who
cares hey hey there we go yep nunim help
oh if you finish your steak already Wow
lady that's pretty impressive huh
there we go waiter check please why do I
need to go to the kitchen again no what
are you made what are you trying to say
huh lady I don't like you're making such
accusations you like the rhythmic
undulation of my arm okay I'm out of
here
excuse me bathroom again nature calls
time to limbo
all right here we go I'm not a rookie of
course he does what the hell happened
here whoa hey hey hey hey well this is
going better than it normally does hey
chef
I'm gonna just mop the floor don't mind
me Oh
Oh
was that the sound of them what do you
mean classifier why are we on fire
safety first
why okay okay okay okay okay okay okay
okay okay okay
the normal situation oh here we go
okay just stick it in the oven oh boy
there yeah this game sure does
big be happy so glad I plan it again not
why that oh no no thank you
yes exactly what I needed okay mom
please
mop away sewing away Danny
why would I forget dessert let me get
that I need to finish mopping this is a
problem chef is ridiculous in hilarious
as this might be for you for me a
professional I okay
welp ah all right there we go okay Thank
You chef I'll just take that out from
under the Hoos and be on my way
hey scar scar I know we didn't order any
dessert and also I didn't know that it
worked here no employee discount by the
way ah I'm gonna get this calmly and
collectively oh ah and there you go
I know you're ready for a little of that
later if you know what I mean I did it
you know it took me twenty one and a
half minutes whoa
okay that was something but either way
it's still
one but oh my goodness it's surgeon
simulator levels of agony sometimes just
cuz oh it doesn't do what I wanted to do
but that's the magic of Octodad so
hopefully you guys enjoyed it let me
know what you think in the comments
below I'm gonna play the other ones soon
you can check out the whole Octodad
playlist it's pretty much that whole
deal that you just saw in an episode in
a series of just watch the playlist down
below click the annotation over there
thank you again everybody for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video let me just do a little sensual
dance up against this you like to split
I do yeah like I said okay gotta get
orange